you should always have a goal it's okay
if you change that goal at
every given time but you always need to
ask yourself
why do you do what you do
[Music]
good morning thank you for having me
michael it's great being here
it is an honor and a pleasure to have
you all the way from the soccer field
from a year or two ago
all the way now and look look how far
we've come you see
no no it's it's really really pleasure
to have you here because
you have one of those unique unique
journeys that i can't wait to hear your
perspective on going from
you know from the political scene from
the spokesperson scene you were very
very active with with various political
campaigns like yeshiva in israel
or being the spokesperson of various
really important figures to going to new
york and being the chief of staff of the
delegation to the un
and then transitioning into you know the
business sector
and and running job it helping people
find jobs
across israel and most recently being
the ceo of the amazing company by me
eh tomer give me a little bit of of
rundown of that transition
why going to politics in the first place
and what what is the trigger that
pushes you more towards business
well i actually i always knew that i
wanted to uh take part in business
but uh right after the army i did five
years of military service
uh fall which in the paratroopers and
then one year as
in the idf spokesperson unit and then
when i when i was done with that i had
the dilemma whether or not i should go
to study full-time or
work full-time and i felt like doing you
know such an amazing
things in the army i felt that i want to
be part of the action
and not only uh go to school and learn
and
and when i when i you know i took a look
at my sets of skills
and spokesmanship was one of them i did
not know anything about
business entrepreneurship being a
manager nothing
and and when i when i look around in the
israeli market i saw that there is an
opening
in the israeli knesset in the israeli
parliament and
and and so i started my career there
knowing that eventually i want to move
into business
but during that time i studied uh my llb
and i was working in the israeli
parliament and so i saw so so again
i knew that that would be the case in
the end actually
five years after i started the politics
i wanted to
do the transition and then i got the
offer to move to new york and be the as
you said chief of staff to the israeli
mission to the united nations
and when that was done and i came back
to israel that was like a
a very natural choice for me
right so tell me a little bit about this
this spokesperson
role because it's a very unique role
that very few people hold right i'm
guessing there is not
too many spokespeople for for the
different groups you've gotten to be
spokesperson both for individuals but
you've also got to be spokesperson for
a whole new political campaign uh yesha
thief so
what what is that role and what are some
of the responsibilities that come with
it
actually the spokesperson pop was like
uh i think 18 months of my
seven years uh career in the political
and diplomatic sector
so uh during those 18 months as you said
i was a spokesman for an israeli
parliament member and then a spokesman
for you can say an israeli political
startup
which was yeah by the way
it was a startup and it felt that way
you know a group of young people trying
to change the world
and being a spokesman a spokesman and a
person is
pretty much uh knowing what is the
biggest advantage of the person
or the entity you are trying to convey
their message in the message
into the public and and making sure uh
the
the public will know the the good stuff
the strengths
and make sure that the the weaknesses
will be left behind
and if for some reason uh the media try
to tackle them
you you provide the right answer so it's
basically conveying a message very
similar to marketing in a sense so i did
that for 18 months as i said and then i
move into
um i will say being a you know a manager
being a uh someone who gets things done
in the political and diplomatic sector
so i was the chief of staff to the
israeli
minister of science and technology uh
former head of
shin bet which is the israel uh you can
say fbi
uh and i i learned a lot from him for
like almost three years
and that prepared me for my uh i'll say
my biggest role at the um which is
basically um you know it's representing
our country
in the most hostile environment uh
diplom
diplomatic-wise and that was uh again
it's incredible
yeah so you find you find yourself in
new york the israeli mission to the
united nations
give me give me the biggest challenge
that you had what was the the most
difficult thing that you encountered
because you know
from from ours from our industry now
very very few people are going to have a
chance to experience
being in such a difficult diplomatic
scene so so paint me a little bit of a
picture of what was the most
perhaps challenging and also
exhilarating part of that whole journey
so i i will try to use an analogy so so
imagine you have a startup and you know
your product is good
it's amazing and uh uh
and you you need to sell that product to
a specific market
and no one in that market is even
willing to sit down
and have a conversation with you no one
you find like two or three
good major clients and you sell them
your product and they feel very
confident
about it and they use it and they are
happy with it but then when you try and
and and take that and broaden it and
moving to the scale mode
you just cannot because no one is even
taking the meeting
and in that right very strange uh weird
uh situation you need to find a way to
get people
to listen and that was i think the main
challenge get people
listen to you and be willing to to
to learn from what you have to say
and that that's incredible and i love
that analogy getting having a product
knowing that it's good having some major
clients but not but others aren't the
market is not willing to even sit down
and listen to you
i i could have had a better comer that
transition
javits you've been a few a few
organizations now you're running by me
if i look at both javid and by me
they're very similar in the sense of
your you're you're making people happy
and it's it's not in the traditional way
of you know just you know sending them
money or sending them a gift basket but
but you're creating opportunities for
people on one hand you're creating job
opportunities
on the other hand you're creating
opportunities for it for unity
for for you know a company-wide a
partnership and for
for people within the company to gift
others so tell me a little bit about
why job it and then we'll move on to buy
me
sure so uh when i came back to israel
i i was debating whether or not i should
go into a big
corporate i had a few offers from big
tech companies in israel
or should i start something by myself
uh and i eventually decided to become an
entrepreneur and
actually found the company and my my
main
issue was back then that i wanted to
make sure that i
as you said i do good i want to make
sure that the things i do and the time i
spend
will will have some sort of a good
impact on people and hopefully on
society as well
so that's when i started uh jobit jobet
is a
an innovative uh placement company who
puts
his uh uh their efforts on helping
people
grow and manage their career uh we were
focusing on uh
ny and gen zed i'm part of that
generation so i i can help
i i know exactly what they need as far
as
career management concern you know we
love to move around from uh
position to position from job to job and
uh
live walking example yeah exactly
exactly and and doing that for for two
years you know building the company
building the the
the product the brand bringing in the
team
and building something that is unique in
the israeli ecosystem
was an amazing experience and i i felt
like uh you know i was doing good and i
learned a lot from the process
and uh and javid is still up and running
uh
as a much better ceo than myself right
now running it
and they're doing a very good job
i love that you know one of the things
that i love about this show is that i
get to take people like you that have
spent now almost three years uh really
being becoming an expert on the gen yj's
gen z market of job seekers and career
seekers
and you get to now teach me in a few
minutes everything that you've learned
or
or some things that you've learned over
those three years so tomer just hit me
what
what are some insights of gen
gen y and gen zed job seekers in the
market
well the the way i look at it and
a lot of very smart people i did a lot
of researches that i
had a chance of reading in the states in
israel
and the main thing i learned is that you
know in the past
when you started a job that job usually
was again i love analogies that job was
the book of your professional life so
you started in chapter one
and you go from chapter to chapter and
at the end you can pretty much
imagine what will be the minute you
start that job you can pretty much
imagine
what's uh gonna look like in the end but
our generation is different
the way we act is we we act more in uh
in a chapter mode so each time you uh
you decide on
on a certain way you want to tackle your
career
and you you you spend a chapter there
if if you're doing a good job so it's
like two years
at a time and the the hard part
is is finding the connection between the
two chapters to make sure that you are
always moving forward
and not moving to the side and that is
why i started job
i wanted to help people manage their
career create a
career path that will help them reach
their goal
and in most cases at the beginning they
don't even know what their goal is
you know the question is uh what do you
want to do when you
when you grow up and where do you see
yourself in in five or ten years time
is not part of the the conversation no
one ever
taught us that this is something we need
to to plan for now
um always when i said that your
follow-up question should be
yeah but how do you know where you want
what you want to do when you grow up
the world is full of different
possibilities and my take on that
is that you should always have a goal
it's okay
if you change that goal at every given
time but you always need to ask yourself
why do you do what you do why do you
spend your most
valuable asset which is your time in
that particular place doing that
particular thing
and that is that is my main take on on
our generation we need to plan ahead and
make sure we do what
needs to be done in order to achieve our
goals
i i i couldn't agree more and i had to
follow through with it with an analogy
of my own i remember
about four years ago when i was
attempting to run a marathon
in a lot and i remember that my coach
told me something that that really that
really helped me at the end finish it
was
it doesn't really matter you know what
happens in these four hours you can't
plan ahead and say my goal is to
finish the marathon in four hours look
at that tree and run those 50 meters
when you get to that tree
reevaluate do you want to make another
goal for another 50 meters you probably
will and then you'll make it
if you plan too far and you get stumbled
along the way
you lose sight of the bigger picture and
how those small steps can be meaningful
and and i think that
you know what you've done with with the
job it is so inspiring and and it's
helped so many people that's that's a
true positive impact because i think
that
i can speak freely for our generation
and i'm a little bit younger than you i
think that i even feel
more you know the we have no idea where
the world is going to end up in in 10 15
years
you know we've accelerated in 2020 about
10 15 years in the future already in
terms of digitalization
you know we're gonna s and i think
mckinsey estimates that we're going to
be changing our careers our
our core career about three or four
times along our lifetime which is insane
and so having a place like javed which
can help you consolidate your thoughts
set those milestones and think more
critically about what type of person you
want to be i love it tomer
buy me you transition from java to buy
me you're going into an existing company
tell me
why and what is by me
well i think the main reason i'll you
know i'll i'll take it in a different
way oh
first of all biome is an amazing company
it has an amazing technological
product who enables people and companies
give gifts to the people they care about
and and just being part of of that kind
of uh of uh
of an environment is is addicting
really uh because as i said at the
beginning uh we do a lot of good in buy
me in our platform
in every less than a minute a a gift is
being sent to someone
and that is that that's amazing the
reason i i see the transitioning
um beside the opportunity to emerge then
i i was approached to
take part in this company uh is
basically i think uh the scale
so uh job it is is an amazing company
with an amazing uh
cause uh but it was relatively small
scale uh back then
and today by me is like i think i don't
know 10 or 15 or 20 times
bigger in uh employees
impact uh p l everything that is
concerned uh
apology company and uh i'm i'm
i love mechanisms okay i'm i'm a manager
and i love setting up mechanism who can
we can create an impact on people on the
people i
manage my employees my team and uh and
that opportunity when when it emerged i
had no doubt that this is uh
this should be my next chapter uh
relating to my phone or
uh i i love it so you mentioned that
by me is about gifting and every minute
somebody gets a gift which is by the way
incredible and i can uh you know i at
the end when we talk about
entrepreneurship i think that again it
comes down to
what can make you feel fulfilled to to
sleep at night well and
i would love going to sleep knowing that
i'm running a company whose product is
that every single minute somebody is
getting a happy gift and is putting a
smile on their face
what is this gifting process and why is
it different or innovative
from the traditional gifting where i can
call there for you or a flower shop and
just send a gift basket to my employees
which was how it was done you know 5-10
years ago traditionally
yeah so by me has been around for about
eight years
and eight years and back then when they
started the company the
original entrepreneurs together with the
uh a group
uh business group called teleclause who
is actually the owner of uh
of biomed today um uh that was exactly
the question people ask them why do i
need this
you know there's a lot of different
opportunities and possibilities to
to give people gifts and employees gifts
and the answer was that our generation
is different
we want to have the ability to choose
our gifts
and you you saw more and more people the
private sector and even in the in the
in the business sector instead of giving
gifts to people
they started giving money if it's
holidays yeah you can buy whatever you
want if it's uh
in the workplace yeah you'll just get a
uh uh this or that bonus
at the end of the month because you did
a good job or you even if you have a
birthday and the reason is that the
the essence of of uh of being able to
choose
is very important and this is you know
this is this is our generation this is
the time we're living in 2020 and back
then 2012.
and and by me saw that and using
technology we have an rd center of about
20 employees
using technology we were able to connect
more than
1200 uh businesses all across israel
and uh using one yeah using one unique
um code you were able to
to use that gift in any one of those
uh businesses and by me you know started
the process of getting people
more and more adjusted and into this new
way of giving gifts
and and making people happy and today we
have about 5 000 business
customers business clients companies who
give gifts to about 1 million israelis
and we actually started like three years
ago our
private sector platform in which we have
hundreds of thousands of israelis who
give gifts to the people they care about
whether it's birthday someone gave both
holidays
etc and and the ability to do something
that is
personal meaning you can you you know
you can use our platform and send them a
a video a photo you can obviously you
write them a very personal
uh uh uh something that they will know
what you think about them
and and why you're giving them this
particular present
and all of this created a personal
process
in which people are receiving gifts and
are happy to use them
and it's amazing i think i think that's
that's remarkable
and it's one of the things that i'm
always very curious about this
transition because effectively
you know you could say here just take
money
use that money as the global currency to
buy whatever you want but money is not a
gift right money is not personal
money is not there's no emotions
connected to money
yet you're creating this currency that
is emotional that
is connected to the gift process of
saying i
appreciate you i'm not just giving you a
bonus but i'm appreciating you
for for all the hard work and for the
person that you are and you're
allowing that currency to be translated
into all these businesses
and i think that's just such a just a
smart and innovative way of thinking
about about our culture and our
new traditions you know the currency is
even more than a gift the currency and
the term we use
is an experience we give you the chance
to
to to get a positive experience right in
your life not many people
not many companies can say they do
exactly that it doesn't matter if you
get a gift card and you choose to use it
in a
you know buy something in a in a h m
okay you can you can use it to whatever
you can go to a luxury restaurant you
can
go to a vineyard you can do a tour in
tel aviv and enjoy the scene
you can do a lot of different things but
again at the essence
is you give a gift which is actually an
experience
and you create positive moments in the
people in the people you care about uh
life and again that's that's amazing
i i love any positive impact on the
people positive
impact on the businesses uh i just love
it tomorrow thank you thank you so much
for being so generous with your time
this was just
amazing and i like i love that i finally
got to learn about you know your past
life which is a full life on its own for
the average person so
so it's really remarkable so thank you
for everything that you've done for
israel thank you for everything you're
doing now for the economy and
and for and for job seekers in the
younger generations
and for gifting to you know people all
over israel and eventually the world
before we leave i have the final
question which is three words that you
would use to describe yourself
uh well i did not think ahead so uh um
so you know let's just do this uh the
first one is two
but i combine them with a dash so that's
fine i think uh is
do force do good
good uh the second word is uh
plan and as i said always have a
plan ahead and the third world which is
actually the first world
if i had to be completely honest uh
family
i love that i love that and anybody
who's a
who's in touch with you on social media
you can see the pictures behind you i
mean
beautiful kids congratulations on
building such a beautiful family
and thank you for being such an
inspiration thank you
thank you very much for having me
michael thank you